hey 42 here it was morning on the
idyllic ebonotal and husband and wife
Russell and Demi were busy processing
the Coconuts they dried for work when
they were disturbed by frantic shouting
they hurried down to the beach where
they found a skinny man with a thick
unkempt beard and long hair dragging
himself through the crashing surf
to say the discovery was a surprise
would be one of the biggest
understatements in all of human history
is part of the Marshall Islands a name
that'll be familiar to regular viewers
as it cropped up in my video on Amelia
Earhart as one of the possible final
resting places of the famous aviatrix
if you've seen that video you may
remember that the Marshall Islands are
one of the most difficult to reach
places on Earth so remote that the US
tested no fewer than 67 nuclear bombs
there after the second World War
when you live somewhere like Evan at all
unexpected visitors are pretty bloody
rare
at first Russell and Demi assumes The
Stranger had fallen off her passing
cargo ship
the truth they would later discover was
Far Far stranger the man spoke only
Spanish and with no common languages
between them Russell and Demi took a
boat ride to Eben natal's main town in
search of help over the course of the
following few days the strange man who'd
emerged from the sea like a hairy Ursula
Andrews began to tell his story and what
a tale it turned out to be
the man whose name was Jose Salvador
alvarenga claims to have gotten lost in
a storm whilst fishing off the coast of
the Mexican state of Chiapas on the 17th
of November 2012 and had been drifting
ever since in the 23-foot skiff that was
still bouncing around in the surf nearby
considering the fact it was now early
2014 if alvarenga was telling the truth
he'd been lost at sea on a tiny boat for
a staggering
438 days
it was an absurd claim and to begin with
most who heard it were understandably
skeptical
how could such a tiny boat have possibly
survived that journey in one piece how
had alvarenga found enough food and
water to sustain himself and why hadn't
he died a scurvy within a matter of
months without access to fruit and
vegetables
[Music]
now if you love traveling like I do then
you'll love the fastest and easiest VPN
surf shark did you know surfshark helps
you to avoid price discrimination based
on your location so you can save money
on plane tickets and car rentals whilst
traveling but if you're unable to travel
then you can even use surf shark to
travel virtually online by visiting
websites that might be banned in your
country or do like I do in use surf
shark to watch Netflix content from
other countries such as America that's
usually blocked here in the UK it's so
easy all you have to do is switch over
your location setting and there you have
it access to all your favorite programs
surfshark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
IP and DNS leak protection an internet
kill switch of your VPN drops out and 24
7 customer support surfshark maintains a
strict no logs policy and their network
of 3200 servers and over 95 countries
runs completely on ramp so they couldn't
plug your data even if they wanted to by
using the Code 42 you'll benefit from an
83 discount plus free extra mums for
free all you have to do is click my
special link in the description below
don't miss out and thanks to Sir shark
for sponsoring this video
the scruffy Mexican had a plausible
enough answer to every question thrown
at him but serious doubts remains after
all what he was claiming simply didn't
seem possible the story soon went viral
and over the following few days
alvarenga was grilled on every aspect of
it the authorities remain so convinced
he was lying that he was subjected to a
polygraph military survival Specialists
and civilian adventurers were asked to
review alvarenga's descriptions of Life
at sea and an oceanographer was
recruited to run computer simulations on
Pacific ocean currents to map the most
likely route a small vessel cast adrift
after Mexican Coast would have taken
but try as they might nobody seemed to
be able to pick any holes in
halvorenga's incredible Tale the
survival experts supported his stories
of how he overcame the Seas many
challenges the adventurers agreed his
experience of life on the open Pacific
Ocean matched their own and the
oceanographer simulations predicted
alvarenga skiff would have passed within
130 miles of ebonotal
eventually someone managed to get hold
of alvarenga's Boss back in Mexico and
he quickly confirmed that an employee by
the name of Jose Salvador alvarenga had
indeed gone missing on the 17th of
November 2012. in a boat matching the
registration of the one now moored of
Eben at all putting all these puzzle
pieces together the world's press was
forced to publish this most improbable
piece Jose Salvador alvarenga was
telling the truth
rewind just over 14 months and a much
rounder less hairy Jose alvarenga was
about to embark on a two-day fishing
trip as far as he was concerned it was a
day like any other and little did he
know as he stepped off the dock and into
his boat he'd spend well over a year
endlessly afloat
the only minor inconvenience at this
point was that his longtime fishing
partner had pulled out of the trip at
the very last minute meaning a
replacement had to be found that
unfortunate soul was 23 year old Ezekiel
Cordoba the two men had never worked
together before in fact they hadn't even
met of course they would soon have more
than enough time to get to know one
another the trip got off to the perfect
start and before long the pair had
landed a bumper catch almost 500
kilograms of fresh fish you could say it
was all going swimmingly but then the
weather changed
picture a particularly dramatic scene
from a perfect storm only replace the
Andrea Gale with a tackney boat one
third the size and with one tenth of the
equipment alvarenga and Cordoba were
sudden to their skins as wave after wave
rammed and slams their solitary skiff
threatening to swallow up the men the
boat and their precious catch speaking
of the couch half a metric ton of tuna
mahi mahi and various species of shark
is the last thing he wants sloshing
around your tiny deck in the middle of
one of the worst storms in years
fearing the careening catch could cause
them to capsize alvarenga made the
difficult decision to dump the lot
overboard
considering the fact the two men would
soon be on the verge of starvation I can
only assume that decision haunted him
for a very long time indeed
the storm raged for a full five days and
its Relentless waves wrecked the boat's
engine and trashed every single piece of
electronic equipment on board crucially
that's included both the GPS and the
two-way radio
alvarenga had managed to fire off an SOS
call to his boss on Shore before the
radio died but with no way of
pinpointing their position it didn't
help all that much a large search and
rescue operation was launched to try and
track them down but the conditions were
still incredibly challenging and the
23-foot skiff with no sales no
structures on the deck and no lights of
any kind was essentially invisible amid
the Towering waves
after two days of searching the rescue
was called off and the men presumed dead
back in this skiff alvaren grin Cordoba
passed the rest of the storm huddled
inside the now empty ice box that had
recently housed their catch when they
emerged cold exhausted and smelling
absolutely awful five days later they
had no clue where they were and the
Horizon now consisted of solid sea water
in every direction in The Cold Light of
Day the two men took stock of their
situation quickly coming to the
conclusion that they were to put it
mildly
they dumped all their food and had
barely any water their fishing gear had
been swallowed by the ravenous waves and
everything that required electricity to
function was frazzled
the most pressing concern was a water
situation a human being can go a
surprisingly long time without food
Scotsman Angus Barbieri survived a
frankly Preposterous 382 days consuming
only coffee tea and vitamins back in the
60s though this before and after picture
should give you some idea of how he did
it he lost 125 kilograms during the
course of what is the longest fast in
history
surviving without water on the other
hand is another matter entirely the
world record for that one goes to
Austrian bricklayer Andreas mahavics who
was somehow locked in a prison cell and
forgotten about in 1979. he was left
there for 18 days before someone found
him by accident
miraculously he went on to make a full
recovery
anyway alvarenga and Cordoba set up a
rain harvesting system using a bucket
that somehow survived the storm and they
improved the setup incrementally over
time with bottles and scraps of plastic
they scavenged from the ocean with the
fishing gear gone and days without
anything to eat leaving the men
desperate alvarenga got
developing a method of catching fish
with his bare hands almost anything that
floats out into the open ocean will
attract a few pissing visitors sooner or
later and alvarenga would hang over the
side of the skiff with his hands
dangling in the water until an
unsuspecting fish swam between them he
would then flip the hapless creature
into the boat with a flick of his wrists
and they're still wriggling dinner was
served
to supplement this Gourmet Sashimi diet
the two men also caught sea birds and
turtles that venture too close to the
boat
these animals came in particularly handy
when the water supply was running low
after a long period without rain
drinking bird and turtle blood can't
have been pleasant but it's just about
better than dying at first all that
animal meat had another benefit too it
contained vitamin C and eaten in
relatively High quantities it just about
staved off the ravages of scurvy when
food was plentiful the two men dried to
fish and meat in the sun on the side of
the boat but when times were desperate
they swallowed whatever they could get
their hands on Gollum style and it was
his habit of necessity that brought
about the Journey's great tragedy
after consuming a meal of raw seabird
Cordoba fell quite suddenly ill and it
soon became clear why inside the bird's
stomach was the half-eating remains of a
poisonous sea snake Cordoba survived the
incident but he was never quite the same
he started refusing food entirely and in
his already weakened State his condition
quickly deteriorated four months into
the journey he passed away
alvaranga was understandably devastated
the two men had grown quite close during
their ordeal and with cordoba's death
alvarenga had not only lost a friend
he'd lost his only link to humanity
the previous four months have been one
long battle against the elements against
starvation and dehydration and against
the constant fear that the fish would
wise up or the rain would stay away just
a few days too long but with the passing
of Ezekiel Cordoba alvarenga had found
himself facing off against another far
deadlier enemy total isolation the
prospect of being alone in that
desperate situation was so terrible that
at first alvarenga simply couldn't face
it he kept cordoba's body with him in
the boat chatting away with his young
friend as if he was still alive
for six full days he chatted to the
corpse whilst nature took its course
until he finally realized he was losing
his mind
the two men had come to an agreement
that should one of them die the other
wouldn't eat the body so alvarenga said
a few quiet words of farewell to his
former friend then rolled him solemnly
overboard he wouldn't set eyes on
another human being for close to a year
of course the oceans aren't entirely
empty and alvarenga frequently saw ships
passing by on the horizon container
ships mostly
colossal floating mini cities that
Traverse some of the most remote parts
of our planet's 139 million square miles
of ocean but despite being some of the
biggest vessels in existence container
ships invariably have very small Crews
usually no more than 20 to 30 people so
eyes on the ocean are limited
alvarenga's tiny skiff was little more
than a speck amongst the endless waves
and he was never spotted it's impossible
to imagine what he must have gone
through as those long months ambled by
we live in an age where people won't
even sit on the toilet for five minutes
without their mobile phones for fear of
being subjected to the tyranny of
boredom Jose Salvador alvarenga spent 10
months alone in a tiny boat with
absolutely nothing
and yet despite the hardships the
dangers and against all the odds he
clung to life day after day month after
month and then one morning his Slumber
was stirred by something strange a flock
of birds circling overhead
seabirds weren't a particularly uncommon
sight for alvarenga he'd murdered his
fair share over the previous 14 months
after all but these weren't like any
seabirds he'd come to know in the past
year or so and there is good reason for
that they weren't seabirds alvarenga
scrambled to his feet and there in the
distance he saw it land
the skiff drifted over the coral barrier
that surrounded what he would later
learn was Eben at all and he dived
headfirst into the water minutes later
the waves tossed his battered body onto
the beach as bad as things had been for
Jose Salvador alvarenga and make no
mistake they had been impossibly
unfathomably bad that moment falling
onto the beach and feeling the sand
between his fingers must have been one
of the most Exquisite experienced by any
human being ever
for the first time in more than a year
his feet were firmly on dry land
ebonotal is a rough Circle comprising 22
separate islands and the one alvarenga
happened to have landed on tile islet
was smaller than a football pitch and
entirely uninhabited but only a few
meters separated from NN itok to the
north and it was there that Russell and
Emmy heard his cries bringing our story
full circle
it feels a bit ridiculous to call Jose
alvarenga lucky but it's worth pointing
out that Eben atoll is the only land for
at least 100 miles in any direction it's
one of the most remote places on the
planet and if his path had been just a
few miles to the North or South he'd
have drifted clean past it the next stop
would likely have been the Philippines
more than 3 000 miles away it's
difficult to sum up a story like
alvarenus it's one of those things the
human brain just isn't capable of
comprehending like the size of the
universe or the price of beer in London
put simply Jose Salvador alvarenga's 438
days at Sea represent one of the most
remarkable Journeys and feat of survival
ever endured by a human being
thanks for watching